we will now look at three app engine
success stories that are representative
because they use two strengths of App
Engine the first one is a real-time
earthquake monitoring system in Japan so
in this picture lots of data is
collected by niat which is an institute
in Japan they look at the data and then
send image files to App Engine
every second clients can then view these
image files to see the activity well as
you can imagine when there is no
earthquake activity there are not many
clients that are interested in watching
this system but on the other hand when
there is earthquake activity the system
needs to serve a lot of data to many
clients and this is of course a great
application for App Engine which can
scale the number of instances up and
down depending on the activity and the
number of clients accessing the system
another great success story of App
Engine is songpop
an app you may have used which is a game
where you guess the song or an artist
well songpop grew from 0 to 10,000
queries per seconds in 6 months and as
of early 2013 it had more than 60
million users songpop uses App Engine
again because of its ability to rapidly
scale up and down based on the user load
and one that you've certainly heard
about is row view the creator of Angry
Birds when Rovio developed a web-based
version of Angry Birds
they used a appengine because of its
automatic scaling but also for many of
the other functions it provides and
these things are exactly what you will
learn when you take this course so stay
tuned